I ended up finding out some capital T
truth and was exposed to year-long text
exchange and went oh I was right about
everything yeah yeah yeah oh okay and it
was actually way worse than I even
thought Anna Kendrick opens up about the
moment she learned her ex was cheating
on her you know maybe just don't seek
that validation
exclusively from people who don't want
to give it to you the Pitch Perfect star
sits down with Dax Shepard on the
armchair expert podcast and without
naming names she reveals that while she
was in a serious relationship she found
a year-long text exchange between her
now ex and another woman a woman he
denied having interest in and he is
screaming at me it was a passing Crush
you're so insecure I never saw a
relationship with this girl to actually
see in writing after a week of [ __ ]
you I want to blow up my life for you
and like just say the word and we'll
ride off into the sunset together Anna
says that when she confronted him he
denied the whole thing he said I don't
know what you're talking about which
again was kind of a relief
oh you're pathological the actress not
only confronted her ex but she says she
also sent an email to the woman inviting
her to have a conversation about the
infidelity to her Eternal credit she was
like yes can I call you wow and we
talked on the phone for about an hour
and she was just like I'm so embarrassed
and I'm so sorry it was her saying it
and and having compassion yeah that was
like oh this was real Anna says she took
some time off of work to focus on her
mental health and started seeing two
therapists a week but now Anna is back
to work and thriving I'm sort of in a
really exciting time in my life last
year it was announced that Anna and
Blake Lively will reunite for a sequel
to their 2018 murder mystery a simple
favor why were you I just
I just bask in this kitchen all day long
maybe you should move in
I've been a fan of hers for a long time
so there's immediate chemistry she just
didn't know about it so it's just been a
real slow burn until I finally you know
convinced her to be in a movie with me
and while we'll just have to wait to see
the two team up again fans can get their
Anna fix in her new thriller Alice
darling I don't know how any of this is
your business Simon loves me I'm happy
ET was with Anna at the Toronto Film
Festival back in September where she
premiered the film but come on we had to
squeeze in a question about one of
Anna's most beloved projects Pitch
Perfect oh I know you're gonna miss me
when I'm gone
the akka amazing film recently
celebrated its 10-year anniversary we
are texting each other exactly what you
think we're texting each other I believe
it's been 10 years you guys are my
family I'm so grateful like I can't
believe these relationships are what
everybody sort of imagines that they are
it's like I'm so lucky to have those
girls in my life
[Music]
foreign